[Music]
let's think to ourselves for a moment
how many of us feel completely ourselves
at work if you did it if you did not
immediately jump to a yes answer to that
question then you are like a lot of
people in the working world and you did
think yes chances are you will be
leading or managing others who will not
answer that question in the same way so
we all have something to learn about
healing or communication to our
identities whenever those identities may
be and identities in the workplace are
increasingly important studies are
showing that job seekers look for more
diversity of identities and inclusion at
work and studies also highlight problems
for example according to one study one
in three women do not feel comfortable
expressing contrary opinions at work
without fear of repercussion so we have
work to do to help us better tailor
identity our communication to our
identities we draw on lessons from
communicating with mastery by JB's from
a chapter 6 of the book he lays out a
framework that leaders can follow to
better authentically communicate to fit
our identities we call this the four C's
clarity confidence competence and
connection as leaders we need to hit on
all four of these to authentically
leverage our identities in our
communication I will start by talking
about clarity and my clarity is
essential for communicators of all
backgrounds but also why I have found
clarity to be particularly important to
me as a gay man clarity is simple it's
really about choosing words and saying
them and a way that removes doubting
ambiguity for your audience to improve
our clarity there are a few rules we can
follow the first is to be mindful of the
diversity of your audience if you are
leading a team
diversity of backgrounds some of the
expressions you might be comfortable
using in corporate America will not
resonate with everyone for example if
you are in professional services you may
have heard people say things like oh
let's just run it up the flagpole and
see if anyone's gonna lose it
a much better way to make the same point
it would be to say let's check with
upper management and see what they think
of our idea so you want to be careful
about using idioms that will not make
your message clear to everyone on your
team second use concrete and specific
language instead of pronouns and
generalities when I first started
working at consulting I had a partner
who used to say that pronouns are poison
when I would present to him and use a
pronoun he would stop me and he would
say wait who is it or who are they and
after many rounds of this I got this
point in seeing when you throw around so
many pronouns antecedents your audience
will quickly lose track of what you're
saying and your clarity will plummet as
a result so your audience will thank you
if instead you avoid some of those
pronouns and use concrete and specific
language instead finally sequence
certainty if I you say to a member of
your team hey it would be is it due on
Friday is that not due on Friday when we
use hedging language like perhaps or
maybe or sort of are kind of we make our
mutt our message much less clear to our
audience so again let's do our audience
a favor and speak with certainty this
way our message will be more clear the
report
[Music]
I have found clarity to be particularly
important to me and my identity as a gay
man before the GSB I was working
overseas in a country with less than
stellar LGBT protections and when I was
talking to a government official our
conversation got into personal chitchat
territories he asked me whether I had a
girlfriend back home I thought about
what to say I decided to say no I have a
partner back home and I emphasized that
word to my appreciation he understood
what I meant and he proceeded to ask me
about my partner back home in Seattle
in this instance one conscious choice of
clear language helped me to make a more
productive and authentic relationship
with this official so I hope that this
gives you some techniques to follow to
improve the clarity of your
communication I'll now pass it to edge a
to speak to you about confidence if a
Boise news says you cannot paint then by
all means paint and that voice will be
silenced
that's Benson mango now we cannot all be
master painters realistically but we all
want ourselves to reach our full
potential and to step into our power
especially as the woman in the audience
too often we get perpetually
underestimated so here are a few
strategies to help us build and project
our confidence strategy number one be
courageous and step up woman research
has found out that our women are very
very unlikely to apply for a job until
they feel they're 100% qualified whereas
men feel a lot more comfortable applying
even when they have just a few of the
qualifications and let me tell you this
holds true even here at the Stanford GSB
recently a female classmate of ours
reached out to me and asked me for help
with her application for venture capital
job a few days later she told me that
the deadline had passed but she hadn't
applied because she felt like she was
under qualified so this is the best
Business School in the world and this
woman had come from a top consulting
and even she had such such strong doubts
about herself so woman in the audience
and the men who are our allies let's
make a commitment to each other to have
a seat at the table and apply for that
job strategy number two so as you can
see woman get interrupted
disproportionately often and so Francis
break from Harvard has a great strategy
for us when we anticipate being
interrupted make your point at the very
beginning of the story so when you do
get interrupted you're still gonna get
credit for having made that point and
then you do get interrupted our very own
Ellison has a great strategy to deal
with it which is with humor and we
examine at the table very confidently
remember Thank You Leila that's a great
point it was also a great point when I
made it ten minutes strategy number
three reduce the apologies again as
Allison has taught us woman's who often
start and end a conversation when I'm
sorry but there's no point for us to
apologize unless we're actually sorry
and as long as we feel like we have a
valid point we should feel comfortable
taking space in the room for example if
there is an act of fire hypothetically
speaking excuse me may I have a moment
is not the right opener an alternative
and potentially life-changing exchange
would be hey there's an active fire
let's go I'm going to pass a possible to
Leila to talk about competence
confidence without competence is a
little bit like icing without cake
delicious but it's probably not
something that you would want to serve
at your dinner table a few years ago at
work I got feedback from my boss he said
that I wasn't doing a good job of
demonstrating my competence why because
I speak pretty confidently relative to
other women so it was difficult for
people to distinguish when I was
strongly stating hypothesis versus
stating facts that I had done a lot of
research on so how do you make sure that
you actually demonstrate your competence
while also remaining true to your
identity there are two main levers doing
good work and actually doing good
preparation good work is relatively
straightforward do your homework put in
the time to prepare on topics that
you're speaking about good preparation
is much more nuanced because it first
requires you to understand the biases
that your audience will have about you
because of your identity then it
requires you to actually deliver the
message that you want to send while
remaining true to this identity and
staying authentic you can do this with
three kinds of speaking tools vocal
tools verbal tools and visual tools for
example as a woman in addition to the
bias that I described at the beginning I
tend to appear smaller younger and more
inexperienced than men and I have less
gravitas what do I do
vocally I try to make sure that my voice
doesn't go up and down in the middle of
my sentences and that I don't end my
sentences on an upward note which is a
common pitfall with females verbally I
try to make sure that I actually have
strong synthesis and that I line up
supporting details behind things that
I'm sure about and then visually I try
to stand straight and take up space to
increase my gravitas remember to stay
authentic in the midst of all of this
one of the best communicators I have
ever worked with was a 5 foot 1 woman
who led a team of army generals I have
such strong memories of her sitting at
long conference tables surrounded by
large men with loud voices she typically
be in a light pink or light
under suit and yes no one ever
questioned her competence because she
acted like herself her voice was soft
yet it would still carry she made her
points and then back them up so stay off
Montek now I'm gonna hand it over to
Mike to tell you a little bit about
connection
thanks Leila that's a great story
in fact stories are one of the most
impactful tools we can use to connect
with our audiences think about story
time when you're a kid or the last
meeting you were in you often remember
the story more than the actual content
JD's Shaun's book talks about the value
of embracing your personal identity to
bring a connection to your audience and
allow them to gain a perspective on your
viewpoint these authentic stories can
make your communication all the more
impactful now one of the identities that
he talks about in the book is that at
the rope now we all know your first few
weeks on the job can be quite
challenging this is actually one of your
best opportunities to build connection
with those around you now let me show
you what my first JM job looked like
before I understood this important
secret hey Mike welcome to your first
day at Stanford Capital Partners let me
tell you a bit about how we run our
Monday morning meeting look look boss I
have a pretty good idea of how to run
this back when I was at Harvard Capital
Partners we started by talking about our
layoffs then about our weekly profit how
do you think that this was a missed
opportunity first we start on a job this
is the ideal time to build connections
to build allies before you ever need
them in other words I need to put
cookies into the jar before I start
taking any out second it's a great
opportunity to ask questions so that
you're curious and hungry as time goes
on it will become much harder to ask
those dumb questions and third I should
avoid references to my prior job and not
think about those differences as raw
well it can be helpful to provide an
outside perspective you need to embrace
the culture and the processes of your
new firm now let's try this one more
time hey Mike welcome to your first day
at Stanford Capital Partners let me tell
you about how we run our
a meeting we usually start by running
through an update on the pipeline of our
exciting projects how does that sound to
you boss that sounds great in fact I was
going to talk about the new
communication optimizer project I have
some great customer stories but I also
think your perspective would be helpful
think you could help me run through the
presentation sure by the way how some
Johnny's baseball team yeah so remember
take advantage of being a rookie build
connections tell stories set yourself up
for success in any new environment so we
hope that you now understand the
importance the four C's well you may not
conquer and master the entire grid you
can use these techniques to improve your
effectiveness as a communicator by doing
so you can embrace your own personal
identity to excel as a communicator and
believe it empower your team's and
inspire your audiences thank you now
like they open it up for questions
[Music]